welcome to another episode of not too
deep the award-winning podcast with me
your host Chris and helping the first
today is a very exciting episode as
always we have Nick Viall here with us
today you might remember I guess you
remember him from The Bachelor or that
guy that you see in a bar like you were
on that TV show with the dating and the
and the you had sex on TV right well
he's more than that
he's a essential oil connoisseur he's
got very strong opinions about the rock
and his grandma Phyllis is a maybe my
new spirit animal so get into this
episode about you deep with Nick Viall
[Music]
this episode of not too deep is brought
to you by you probably guessed it
Squarespace turn your great idea into a
reality with Squarespace they make it
easier than ever to launch your passion
project whether you're showcasing your
work selling products of any kind
they've beautiful templates and the
ability to customize just about anything
so you can easily make a beautiful
website all by yourself but if you do
get stuck Squarespace is 24/7
award-winning customer support is there
to help head to Squarespace comm such
grace for a free trial and when you're
ready to launch use the offer code grace
grac e to save 10% off your first
purchase of a website or domain oh thank
you I made it myself
did you yeah I like to really broadcast
exactly how I perceive myself to the
outside world you think you're an idiot
yeah I don't know anything about
anything I like to think it's self aware
I don't what did your shadow buy that
room room service I got our sales okay
so we each are sending messages with
clothing I will bring you your food
Thanks Thank You NIC vile vile vile bye
okay this is the thing that we've
started this season of the podcast is
that I start by asking every guest
what's your deal what's my deal like why
am I the way I am it's a great question
that's a I'm on that journey trying to
figure that out huh I get back to you
yeah yeah
I mean hopefully we uncover what your
deal is throughout this podcast I'll be
great I feel like this will okay my
problems so I obviously like we talked
about a little bit low-hanging fruit is
to talk about The Bachelor how much of
your life is consumed by that now like
when you wake up and you do your day
every day how much of it is like
Bachelor oriented based like faceted not
much really no okay is the assumption
that it is yeah that's fair yeah do you
feel one do you think your social media
profile is a direct reflection of you no
not at all
I mean I try I try to be as like
authentic quote/unquote and to use that
word authenticity that gets thrown
around with like social media people as
I can I don't I try to curate a
beautiful profile it doesn't often work
that way yeah I mean when it comes to
social I I plus I always joke with my
friends if I was never on The Bachelor I
would I wouldn't even have Instagram
really I mean I'm I'm older so like you
know before like my stepmom I just found
out has Instagram and she likes every
single post before like I didn't like
take pictures I mean I you know I dated
and when people didn't have I can't like
they had camera phones but it was those
shitty flip phones and if I didn't have
a girlfriend
I like disappeared off the planet
unsocial like you always knew if I had a
girlfriend because on Facebook sure dude
let's take a picture you know like she
post a bunch of pictures and then we'd
break up and I'd go dark for like on
MySpace like what guy is like hey we
should definitely take a picture hey you
can you take a picture of me right now
I'm gonna okay so now I do that but I
only do it because you know my followers
primarily bachelor nation and so you
know I people have why do you only post
pictures with people and bachelor nation
it's like because every time I post a
picture with like my hometown buddy
you're basically telling me to [ __ ] off
because you're like I don't care likes
it's just like yeah we're not interested
people what they want
I'm here I don't that's why I have it
so this seems like it causes you a lot
of trauma no we're starting off with but
yeah no I
I certainly am fortunate to have the
platform that I have and and bachelor
nation is not even that but like when
when it comes to work or the things I do
I get asked a lot about it yeah what is
the question you hate getting asked the
most I mean that's up there no it's it's
there's no one question it's just more
it's the second question whatever that
is okay you know it's okay I don't want
to I don't want to bother you okay but
is it video yeah yeah really I just told
you it is I don't believe you but like
do you regret it no you don't are you
sure okay what's your life like like a
bachelor nation what do you mean what do
you do what's your deal you get
questions like that a lot yeah I get
questions like that a lot what do you
what do you do my dog what do I do
well a lot of my time recently in the
past year has been spent on my central
oil company yeah okay I want to get into
that because this seems I brought you
some what okay we'll get into free gifts
in a second swims talk us through how
this happened
is there something you've been into as a
sighting that's personally used
essential oils for about five years my
sister really my sister Maria she's a
certified holistic nutritionist yeah so
she turned me on and that just because
she as a holistic nutritionist she's
obviously been big on like alternative
forms of homeopathy homeopathic you know
but she's big on diet but like that
expands to other things I have terrible
anxiety yeah I just like a unique
person's like hey guess what I'm gonna
admit mine
I think finding like more natural ways
of healing anxiety rather than just like
popping pills I'm not saying I met like
I don't like to self-medicate I don't
like to do that I understand that that's
not a choice other people get to make
but I tried to look for other forms of
and and so I tried skeptically essential
oils okay and sure why not you know like
so I tried them they helped and in what
way did you try it like how for someone
that doesn't know anything about
essential oils is it like you put them
on your wrist you put them on your
forehead you like you can do both
traditionally essential oils a lot of
people have diffusers and so you put
them in a diffuser and you'll get pure
essential oils kind of walk through this
certainly a better alternative candles
especially if you know the ideal like
candles or you don't realize that you're
literally burning toxins into the air
take that bath and Bodyworks eat [ __ ]
I mean it's true your skin is your
largest organ for those of you who don't
know anything that your organs absorb
ultimately ends in your bloodstream and
so whether it's through breathing things
in or applying it directly to your skin
it all ends up in your body and in your
blood so when you're burning candles
you're obviously it's all ends up in
your body and so people with essential
oils will primarily diffuse them you can
put essential oils on your skin
we have roll-ons you can do that yeah
you have to dilute them with a carrier
oil that can be a whole oil that we use
people can use almond oil or other other
cheaper always if they want because
essential oils have their high and very
they're very high in potency yeah so if
you were to put pure essential oil
directly on your skin without diluting
you could you know break out in a rash
you don't want to do that watched as a
lot of people would diffuse them so
either you have to dilute them or not
which is when I started using essentials
I find it very complicated I was just
like some like dude is a contrast and
Royals and a message like what you have
to do this this and that you know find a
bit like their stats right you can blend
them blend when you blend them you can
maximize their effectiveness especially
with other essential oils so like you
can have like for example our one blend
has grapefruit oil
oil and peppermint oil okay and so when
you you maximize those you can impact
their medicinal effect again wash low
can be confusing so natural habits is
they have in the company we try to my
goal of starting it was I wanted to make
essential values kind of more mainstream
and easier for people like me who you
know I aren't you know traditionally
into holistic remedies you know if
you're my sister great you're into all
that stuff you're you're super it down
and a lot of people so it's it's more
traditional also in an initiative that
if you aren't familiar about I'm nerding
out in essential oil essential oil
business is predominantly the two
biggest companies are multi-level
marketing companies okay oh yeah we just
had just like whatever fine listen to
the dream podcast ever yeah but I found
it surprisingly interesting that it was
hard for me as a user to find an
essential oil company that were
certified USDA Organic they're just
they're not as prevalent which I found
interesting given that like it was
almost like a contradiction of like the
end of like holistic remedies really
important what you put in your scanner
on your body like ends up in your
bloodstream but like I couldn't verify
or verified organic and then like you
know some of these MLM companies like
they call themselves therapeutic
creative not to like get into it cuz
like some people it's pretty easy to
find out that like therapeutic grade
isn't backed by anything you know they
yeah yeah it's like it's backed by
people who are like hey do you want to
call my stuff they're like certain
award-winning podcast but that's barely
because my parents think it's awesome
and so so that was kind of the genesis
of starting it so we source from several
different farms been in the making its
we working at for over a year trip like
sourcing the farms getting you know I
don't we don't own our own farms right
we've sourced from farms that
can have the standards to get us tea
organic certified to assurance um you
know I need it so you've done to get
USDA Organic certified as a whole
process you got to make sure like the
soil there's no contamination or
anything like that there's a there's a
lot that goes into that so we are
probably USDA Organic certified we only
just do blends right now we want to keep
I want to keep it simple
yeah for the average person who wants to
get into it who doesn't have the time to
like read up on what blends do what yeah
yeah so that was that's kind of how it
all started so this is just the
beginning of it yeah we we've only been
selling for since early November very
very new I mean the companies are in
existence for over a year but we have
only been on the market for what does
your sister think she's she loves it
she's a part of it
she's been I think you gotta give her a
cut yeah she's a great resource you know
in terms of when we were designing the
blends and things like that
I got her feedback obviously in some
other aromatherapy experts were part of
that process as well and then also like
just my person I would I use and what
helped me yeah what's your go-to like if
you had to recommend to someone that's
like brand new to this kind of world of
essential oils like what's your I mean
peppermints a big one just because you
know a lot of people use it struggle
with headaches and I did as well in our
our blend are you carrying Thanks
so peppermint I mean I figure just a
single oil again we you know we have
other blends we use like tea tree oil
and our protect one and eucalyptus oil
all these only and they have a ton of
different properties that can impact you
and have its benefits so that's super
yeah that's fascinating cuz I feel like
you've probably been through a lot in
terms of your world over the last like
few years and so anxiety is I think
something that a lot of people struggle
with probably not on the level which
you've had to deal with it so it's
interesting to see that this is your
go-to yeah
like to blame the bachelor or my
experience I mean I've always struggled
with Chris Harrison provides anxiety for
all of us I personally find like for me
it's like it's more I'm just a heavy
person I'm in my analytical and that
just kind of perpetuates the The
Bachelor never helped yeah what's your
okay I can't see I get anxious by proxy
just like understanding what your like
life is and journey is what is the most
regular kind of interaction you have
with people on the street that come up
to you because I remember this is a very
funny story so you shot a video with my
friend mamrie Hart yeah years ago and
then we went to the women's March the
first year down in downtown LA and then
she we were like there with our friend
like hanging out doing our thing and
then like we were trying to leave and it
was so crowded and all of a sudden she
just goes and she like screamed at you I
was like who are you talking to she's
like that was the bachelor we shot a
video in my kitchen at Sheep it's like
was like this is the way and so that was
my first inner introduction to who you
were was my friend mamrie screaming at
you from behind at the women's March
most most of time and that was the
height of I mean I was literally The
Bachelor
yeah and like it was maybe two weeks
after the premiere of my season that
that was it that's interesting you bring
that up because that particular day I
mean for the most ninety ninety percent
of people come up our lovely nice just
want to say hi maybe maybe they want a
picture and 99% of the time like no
problem
view your questions take your picture
the woman's mark that was the first one
is March that was the season and I
actually I didn't take any pictures
there so I was politely trying to I was
saying no wasn't that it was just like I
you know I didn't want to like obviously
because what happens in those crowds is
one person asked for a picture and you
say yes and then a munch people do and
all of a sudden I just I didn't feel
comfortable showing up in a crowd that
was about this like very momentous
moment um and just trying to be there a
supporter like distracting for me I just
felt really uncomfortable that so I
didn't take pictures didn't you know and
I you know pisses some people off well I
had really interaction interesting
interaction last Saturday and get most
people really nice in this particular
and I could sense it I mean I'm not the
my resting gaze can be unpleasant you're
resting gaze can be unpleasant Wow I
mean if that's not on your tinder bio I
don't know what you're doing like I'm
not like consciously always being like
smile dick you know like that's a much
more complicated way of saying the of
resting [ __ ]
yeah again I I do I can get anxiety or
like an awkwardness
you're a human being and I also like I
also like I like being like but not to
the point I have some friends I always
give like you know if you watch so Ben
Higgins because he is always on always
on yeah he's always just like politics
yeah always this and he's very gracious
and he's very nice and I certainly try
to be but sometimes I'm like I don't
care that's so much more fair because
yeah my friends are the same way that
like we make fun of my friend Hannah
because she becomes a cartoon character
version of herself a lot of times and
then all of a sudden she like turn it
off completely and so it's like one or
the other
yeah there's gotta be some middle ground
I try my best but in this I went on
Saturday mm-hmm my buddy is in town from
New York and we went to this restaurant
bar to grab a drink just might like just
two guys standing casual and out of
nowhere this this young lady very nice
walks up with this with this guy she's
like hey it's kind of like and it's one
of those things it's always tough
because what I appreciate what I would
prefer someone is saying hi I'm
so-and-so big fan or I like I look may
have a picture sure here's a question
thanks for answering it have a great
night yes fine that's that is a to the
point but this like again like also
you know it's I'm a few a few years
removed it's not like especially in LA I
don't get to certain cities are
different but yeah you go about my day I
don't like I'm not like oh don't look at
me you know whatever I don't even think
about the show in that ends but like
sometimes and people come back and kind
of tell where this is going yes she's
just like hey you know I just
hi and just not really say anything just
kind of stand up looking at me and like
hey and her friend like probably a few
drinks and is just kind of like hey just
they're just kind of like they walk up
and say hey what's up you know I don't
know this time are you brother and
sister are you dating a husband and wife
I don't know what is going on happening
and then you know like you she could
tell like in it clearly I'm like I could
tell this was like a bachelor fan she's
like well you know I didn't know if you
I'm sorry for like awkwardly staring at
you I don't know if you notice no I I
did I know I didn't know like there's no
right answer to that no yeah exactly I
notice or no I so the question is like
do i how do I know you
yeah I know you from somewhere how do I
know you and I can't be like TV I play
dumb and it's like I don't know I don't
know
no but I'm you're you're on that show
right yeah yeah I guess about that
bachelor show right but actually she
didn't say that but that happens all
yeah
and so she she just kind of looks at me
I'm like hey and she was tough she was
very sweet very nice yeah and then her
friend like kind of takes over kind of
like I'm like I'm gonna drive the car a
mess up so he just starts like
accurately like going to my friend she's
like so
so uh what are you like so you live here
he's like I know I live in New York
I like well what part and he like tells
them it's go I just live in that part
you like making conversation
do you mind like two strangers walk up
to us and just start like drilling us
with questions and he said well what do
you what do you do my friend is like
works in PR so he's like he kind of he
gave him a very like vague like I work
in social media PR Oh interesting what
specifically oh just like drilling I'm
just like Jesus that is abrasive like
wow and I'm just like kind of protecting
my friend I'm like I'm really sorry he's
getting drunk now I appreciate this guy
he's just trying to like woman
like it turns out he's like married to
this girl's sister oh boy
oh I don't know what to say so I'm
trying to like I I don't want to date
her and I'm happy to answer a few
questions but she's just kind of hanging
out looking at me and I'm like okay I'm
not man I don't know like I know I I'm
in a tough call right so I just don't
I'm not very conversational eventually
they try to get the point because then
he turns to me he's like oh so do you
live in LA
oh my god I live in a way where I
appreciate like he's trying to like she
saw you he talked her up and said I'll
go over with you have a shot let's go
over here because when it comes to the
bachelor people have this weird thing
about it because it's not the same well
I got a guy like a real like celebrity
what's this like well that's your it's
like you know someone that's Nick and I
the brother-in-law of it gives a [ __ ]
about this guy let's go talk to him and
then they get up there and they're like
oh [ __ ] what do we say now you know
anyway so then like this girl like they
leave and the next day like out like I
was doing my question with Nick so I'll
check my yeah and she literally writes
me she's like it's such a shame you like
had to be such a jerk I just wanted to
say hi yeah and I get all bummed about
it and I actually like do I ever bother
writing back and I wrote back I'm like
not my intention is very nice incredibly
clean you're never one or one percenters
funny that she got the balls to write
you and be like you were you were an
[ __ ] while I stared at you in silence
you also by the way I love the
contention that I know it's like a
conversation starter but when you ask
someone what do you do yeah and you
barely know them yeah it's kind of an
offensive question and I don't use the
word offensive lightly okay would you
walk up to someone and within minutes
of knowing them I would say how much
money do you make
no that's not the question no but how
much different is it you problem then
that's how much different is it like how
like absurd like would you do that would
you ask someone how much money they make
look I'm a youtuber so I've been faced
with this [ __ ] in general if you say
well I'm a lawyer I'm a teacher these
are certain different ways you can make
but what but that's not the question the
question is what do you do for a living
cuz if he said I'm a teacher and then he
goes oh my gosh the teacher strike this
is insane
blah blah now here's a new conversation
sure I'm not asking hey what's your tax
bracket sir I'm talking about the first
two minutes of meeting someone yeah what
do you do what do you do what do you ask
- like like create actual conversation
if I were like I don't walk up to like
strangers this is a hypothetical
situation there's no consequence
oh girl like hacen but I'm saying I
don't walk up to strangers - straight
conversation I mean yes in a dating
situation if I might walk up to a girl I
was like have she's cute let's sure and
what do you lead with I know maybe
something witty if I can think of it
otherwise it's like hey like what can I
buy you a drink is easy and then it's
like what do you do so what do you do
for work are you qualified to do this or
I mean that's the weirder one it's it's
a bits of personal like and people can
get defensive what if what if you're in
between jobs what if you hate your job
what if you say all of that today you
know I don't know keep it easy but then
you need to write a book on exactly how
to come up and talk to you specifically
so that everyone can avoid having a deal
I don't think a lot of people like to
answer that question what you do in the
first minute
so I think it's you have a problem
because your job is so undefined that
you don't want undefined I can go all
day about all the things I said what's
your deal what's my deal yeah I found an
essential oil company I have a podcast
host ideally you can answer this
question it's taken us 25 [ __ ] minutes
to get it was rigged what's your deal
afraid that's not what do you do what is
your deal like what my deal is
aye-aye sir at the wall and contemplate
life and then come back with more Nick
Viall
live via via Nick Nick
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you have a bunch of stuff lying around
the house that you just don't use a pair
of jeans that was only worn once or an
old phone hiding in the drawer somewhere
we all have it and I'm Akari is an app
that can help you sell all of this stuff
they make it fast and easy to sell
almost anything you simply take a few
pics of your stuff add a description and
boom your item is listed once it's sold
Macari emails you a shipping label and
you just send it off
there's no meetups with strangers no
hassles that is ideal for me with Macari
you can sell everything from fashion to
electronics and toys to Sporting Goods
over 100,000 items get listed on Macari
every day earn a few extra dollars and
clear up valuable space in your home
with Macari the app has over 300,000
reviews on the App Store with an average
4.8 star rating so why not give it a try
don't let that stuff you don't use go to
waste
sell it ship it and get paid with Macari
you can find Macari on the App Store or
on Macari calm that's ME are CA are I
Macari the selling app this episode of
raunchy deep is brought to you by 3rd
love with more than 70 sizes including
their signature half cup sizes 3rd love
designs bras with breast size and shape
in mind for a perfect fit and premium
feel you just answer a few simple
questions via 3rd loves fit finder quiz
to find your perfect fit in 60 seconds
that's all then thanks to 3rd loves 100%
fit guarantee you can wear wash and put
your bra to the test for 60 days and if
you don't love it you can return it and
third love will wash it and donate it to
a woman in need this is hands-down the
most comfortable bra you'll ever own
with straps that won't slip tagless
labels and lightweight super thin memory
foam cups I am Telling You and I'm not
lying they have sent me a couple of our
products and I absolutely does love them
so much as a creature of comfort they're
so wonderfully fantastically comfortable
I can't say enough good things about
them third love knows that there's a
perfect bra for everyone so right now
they're offering you beautiful listeners
15% off your first order go to 3rd love
comm slash grace now to find your
perfect fitting bra get 15
setting up your first purchase that's
third love calm such grace for 15% off
today we're back with Nick Nick V I'm
glad I mean he's just been venting
venting venting V is for venting I'm
just trying to give you a good show
Thank You how's Phyllis Phyllis is great
thank you that's your grandmother your
beacon of hope yeah I wouldn't phyllis
when i was i've only call her fella
found clara grandma yeah no and that's a
yeah she doesn't look like a freshie
when i was born she was in her mid 50's
and she was not ready to be called to
see the badass grandma so she's always
been Phyllis to me did she keep up with
your whereabouts yeah she's she's pretty
honest she's pretty
when my dad was in high school my my
grandfather left her okay so she raised
five you know this is like in the 60s
yeah
he raised five kids on her own and she's
a true badass she's true badass who
worked in corporate America before it
was like a thing for women to do that
that's amazing
yeah and so she's a she's a big sports
fan she was my roommate for a while I
don't know how you're not pitching that
as a pilot like that sounds like a great
job well I was briefly engaged in my
mid-20s and we broke up and we lived
together at a time and my I was living
in Milwaukee and Phyllis lived downtown
III preferred not to live with a girl
who had cheated on me that I was engaged
with so I was like hey fellas can I
crash deeper come on she is a great
roommate doesn't it until like 3:00 in
the morning and talk sports oh here's
what I would do I would go out I'd have
some games with my friends and I would
come home should still be up knitting
and I would like download my knight be
like and I met this girl I'm not really
sure
do you have rights to this story because
I'm gonna write this pilot that you got
cheated on there you go move in with
Phyllis and she
get started now that I'm thinking about
it it's like two guys a girl but it's
one guy at an old woman and a knitting
complex and she's she's a cool hang we'd
go to you know burger games and talk
sounds like the like quintessential wing
woman she's great yeah she can hang yeah
has she found love
does she need it you know she wouldn't
do you know she obviously got to for
divorce from my grandfather and my whole
life she was always dating some
super-rich dude and then when he would
die she would
two weeks later find another rich dude
they did the wealthiest man and they
would like die and like two weeks later
she'd have a new boyfriend can you give
me her contact info because I would love
to have her on an episode of even by
proxy like remotely if we can Skype her
in I would love like I could learn on
what photos where'd you get this very
clearly expensive piece of art well I
was from John what happened to John well
he's not with us anymore she's perfect
she's absolutely perfect what does she
think about everything you've done with
your life she thinks it's cool is it not
I don't know I mean like you went to get
I grew up in Wisconsin like people think
it's for the holidays because you have a
big family right
well I always joke I you know like where
I grew up and I mean it was cool to be
like stopped by the 5 o'clock news you
know minute witness number three you go
home and set your DVRs I give my two
cents on the street burglary that
happened that I saw and that was really
cool so like give me [ __ ] to be on The
Bachelor okay give me this the quickest
sparknotes version of how you got on The
Bachelor my my best friend's wife is a
huge fan of the show she washes it I was
at his house
she nomination and I made fun of her for
watching the show and then she decided
to be make more sense to sign me up so
she pranked you real hard she fully
pranked you she got you on the show
yeah I didn't really familiar with the
premise and I just like literally like
what the [ __ ] are you watching what is
this this makes no and because I'm like
it's in the background right I'm like
half watching it and you know you hear
things like well you know today I I went
on my date with Laura and I broke up
with Sam and I'm just like and it's like
huh what what the [ __ ] is like what are
you watching yeah like yeah totally
normal yeah that makes sense
do you feel you have to watch this
season do I have to but no but obviously
I get asked about it season we were just
talking about that before you guys I
think it's a great season you don't like
it I are you a bachelor fan I so I
started watching after mamrie did this
thing with you like she had been
watching forever I was not I love
reality TV I'm a housewives through and
through I never want I mean I don't I've
I got really high a couple months ago
and watch Real Housewives for the first
time and then that that's when I first
realized like by myself I was like oh
this is bad they're scary and mean and
yeah and it's the first time that I like
realize outside of my body I never
really got into any other so you you do
you have watched recyclable TV like it's
like you know music in the background
but it's not music is much more
fulfilling but so I think I started
watching with a bunch of girlfriends I
think the very end cuz Raven Wright was
on your season yeah like that's then and
it just was like Raven going I've never
had an orgasm before and I was like what
the [ __ ] is this and she's just wearing
a giant hat in the snow is all I
remember I was just like that was the
first episode that I watched that was
yeah with a bunch of girls that were
like no talking and I was like I have so
many questions
I personally am enjoying this season I
realized this is what don't you like
about it
everything can be more specific I mean
my is the fact that if you're 29-yard
cougar yeah well one they're all 23
which is weird because they all made a
big deal about Becca being like 2200
weird
his television right but then I love
that Chris Harrison accidentally called
the beauty queen by the wrong name I was
like awesome I was so specific and
purposeful and I was like that's not a
mistake
this is scripted this is [ __ ] scripted
we also had Thomas Middleditch that
doesn't make it scripted yeah fully does
how does that make it scripted there's a
producer that goes this is gonna be good
TV you just say the wrong name of course
what I always tell people it is
incredibly stage there's a and then he's
just this big stick that comes in and
stirs it sorry I know a lot about the
show but tell me what do you know about
this it's incredibly stage it's very
stage the situation's are say certainly
Chris Harrison has a lot of inside
information and of course he went in
there me like I'm gonna like but what
they do is they create a very stage
environment in a very controlled
environment with absolutely zero
distractions about what except what's in
front of you and at that point they say
go yeah and the conversations that
happened after that between the bachelor
or the Bachelorette and it's Kay are
very real I believe that we had Thomas
Middleditch on an episode and he's a
super fan of The Bachelor Middleditch
news on Silicon Valley okay yeah really
great comedian and he got to go to set
and visit during becasuse probably
friends along yeah yeah and so he Elan
musk know and so he went he was like it
was the most incredible thing to see
because it's you're watching this like
date happened but then you're watching
this like echo chamber of people
watching this date happen and then other
people watching this date happened he's
like it was the most intense experience
that I've ever seen and just to hear
this person that is like a comedian that
does have like you know very funny takes
on things think that it was the most
intense thing that he see and I was like
yeah I bet you're in this [ __ ]
like it's the Stanford Prison Experiment
have you seen that they put you into
like a snow globe
we've not become a product of your
environment yeah there's some up it was
basically a story about this Stanford
professor that wanted to see how people
would adapt in the product of their
environment and so he got a bunch of
college students and he's like okay you
four people are guards and you four
people are inmates and the guards you
had like in you know as a poor college
student so like to do the experiment you
would make money so that they were like
well we have to do this could we make
money and by like three days they had to
shut down the experiment because the
guards became so abusive to the inmates
and they just became a product of their
environment okay question for you about
social media is there any who are you
obsessed with following on social media
is there anyone that you hate follow
love follow I'm not no I mean I'm more
for me I as a user I get more value on
Twitter
okay so what's what's because I'm a big
sports fan okay and so I also like and
curate my own news I try to have a broad
spectrum but that's where information
and articles usually are leaked so I
like it for information sure as a sports
fan it's great toe okay this is gonna
come out after the Super Bowl
but what's your prediction of the Super
Bowl I mean I guess I hope the Rams win
just like as a sports fan that's a very
lacks and I was really hoping for a
Chiefs Rams game did good on the
Patriots hey it's impressive what
they've done but it's just it's boring
for two years
yeah Wisconsin that's right that's right
that's right that's right yeah I'm just
not as excited for the for the Super
Bowl this year because of that but
that's what I in so in terms of my
favorite follows I don't know I mean
there's no one's blowing my mind on
Instagram who's blowing your mind
so I can't wake up mr. Bub's is blowing
my mind it's this dog that only goes all
the time and is it how new how recently
have you been following mr. Boies the
last four weeks four weeks how long how
sustainable do you think this like but I
will say mark ruffalo on Twitter blows
my mind good he's great he's so
politically active he's also just like
tongue in cheek he's just like so in the
know of his own like brand his own like
self and he just like does whatever he
wants he doesn't feel like he's owned by
any studio it's just like he is very
cool on Twitter so I'm sorry that I have
like real genuine like for people I
don't like I've like for people not
necessary there yeah I have people I
follow I enjoy following Ryan Reynolds
is pretty good it's not on there much
when he does it's pretty good yeah he's
very special
I follow the rock I don't know why I do
too I mean what is it we have to be
social currency like he very impressive
what he's done
yeah you know I have an acting coach I
have dabbled in it no oh yeah and so
when people say to me like I mean like
how who has ever made it and I'm like
well the rock was a wrestler and I'm not
comparing myself to the rock but in
terms of someone who's gone from a
reality TV show which is wrestling to be
and the biggest movies he's a motivation
there he also laughs at his own jokes
before he tells them and I have a big
issue with that from for human beans
okay doesn't it go don't you think so
when someone's like you could ask the
question and if it's like an odd
question it's like hey what do you think
what this you're like oh yeah I'd like
this insincere laugh that you know I'm
talking about people drop the rock does
it all the time
and it really that
and I respect that he's very talented
also I would challenge the rock to post
an Instagram with no caption and to see
what happens because his captions are
just essays essays essays full TED talks
he's doing something right acting yeah
you're in a Christmas cruise yeah I've
never seen it how's it you haven't seen
it okay what was your part in a
Christmas cry was Bob the hotel cruise
manager which is funny because I shot it
last year I never saw so I came out for
the holiday season last year and it was
gonna be played every Christmas she's
already a Vivica a fox and had a couple
scenes of dinner car thought that was
pretty cool
but apparently it blew up I mean once
they blew up this holiday season because
no one really liked tag me even all
through Christmas everyone's like
tagging me like okay what's your ideal
role to play if you're taking acting
lessons and you're doing that whole
shtick what's your like do role I mean
when it comes to my acting career I've
been lucky enough to get some roles I
was on speechless at a guest star role
on teachers yeah I'm just trying to take
my time I've actually turned I mean I
turned down a lead role in a like a
movie that you know I just didn't think
I was good enough to carry a movie on my
own I didn't feel I felt like I like
things done casted so in terms of I
didn't and the advice I've gotten some
other people in the industry is there
should be a one thing about a role that
you should take it maybe it's money
maybe this is gonna be great we're gonna
pay you a [ __ ] ton of money you're like
okay or maybe it's the director or
script or some other actor you get a
chance to work with and yes the
particular role didn't have any of that
and I didn't feel comfortable enough and
I thought it had a really good chance of
being bad when it comes to my acting
career I just I I'm doing the work i I
have a coach I work every week on it and
I would rather play the long game I'm
lucky enough that I don't have to book a
role to make a living yeah and so I'd
rather play the long game so that if I'm
working off
to look a few smaller roles with some
you know legitimate shows or other
actors that I have an opportunity for
people to look at and go it's actually
but and I thought I think that's kind of
my acting plan that's incredibly smart
of you though it takes five years to do
that than great that's great though
because you want the right part at the
right time it's all timing situation I
think that's like very very very
self-aware of you to do that kind of
situation because especially out here
like you take every opportunity that's
given to you because you don't know if
there's gonna be another one and then
unfortunately sometimes they're bad
opportunities it's not like as if Bob
the hotel cruise manager was like yeah
this is gonna be great and it was fine
but you know I got to like sticky and
fun it was pretty cool yeah and you know
and that was also my very first movie so
I had to do something and it's gonna be
replayed every holiday season every
holiday season the only thing about that
is when I when I booked the role an
audition and at first it was this hotel
cruise manager and my agent being the
wonderful talented agent that she is
made sure that I got a name a title and
that I got Bob they had the entire list
of names in front of them they kept okay
any name Bob is great Bob I think that's
more memorable in Venna than a James
than a Chris than any of that and maybe
they're like you know what fine you want
to make us give him a name [ __ ] him he's
gonna be Bob I've offended the rock in
all the Bob's of the world yeah I know
that the only people that listen to this
podcast are Bob's in the rock so we're
gonna take a quick break when we get
back we're gonna get into the Twitter
questions cuz there's a lot I mean as
you can imagine we'll be right back with
Nick Vince here do I sound angry no as
you cut your essential oil
[Laughter]
[Music]
this episode of not too deep is brought
to you by our dear dear BFFs
over at Squarespace turn your dream into
a reality with Squarespace they make it
easier than ever to launch your passion
project whether you're looking to start
a new business showcase your work
published content sell products and more
Squarespace is the tool for you they
have beautiful templates created by
world-class designers and the ability to
customize just about anything with a few
clicks so you can easily make a
beautiful website yourself Squarespace
is powerful ecommerce functionality lets
you sell anything online and analytics
help you grow your site in real time
everything is optimized for mobile right
out of the box and there's nothing to
patch or upgrade ever buying domains is
simple and you'll get the help you need
with Squarespace is 24/7 award-winning
customer support swear space empowers
millions of people from designers to
lawyers artists to gamers even
restaurants and gyms to turn great ideas
into something head to squarespace.com
slash grace for a free trial and when
you're ready to launch use the offer
code grace to save 10% off your first
purchase of a website or domain that
squarespace.com slash grace offer code
grace ever finished a workout feeling
sore too exhausted to function not with
pee valve pee valve is the opposite of a
grueling high-impact painful workout
it's a completely science-based method
based on mastering precise movements
that activate hard-to-reach muscles to
create beautiful natural muscle tone in
less time using less energy stream
workouts ranging from 15 to 60 minutes
with new classes each week on the P
valve app or online shape calls P valve
quote the burns so good workout that
Victoria's Secret Angels swear by it
what is not to love about that
download the app watch tutorials and see
dozens of before and after pics then try
P vol free for one month and get 50% off
the premium P valve equipment kit at P
valve comm / grace this is the best deal
that they have anywhere and get a free
trial for one month and 50% off the
premium peeve of equipment kit at P
valve calm such grace once more that's P
valve calm / grace
okay we're gonna get into some Twitter
questions with you Nick but before we do
I'm gonna ask you the two questions
asked every single guest that's on the
podcast and the first is who alive or
dead would you most wanna throw cold
spaghetti act cold spaghetti oh yes sir
follow up questions live I mean I guess
alive I don't have anything against the
dead move okay Rock I love the rock but
you can use some cold spaghetti I could
picture a lot the rock getting cold
spaghetti throwing on his face yeah and
then awkwardly laugh about it pretending
it doesn't bother him but just fuming on
the inside no one throws spaghetti at
the rock have a great summer I'm
covering the Nick vile Rock Vendetta
now it starts here to check the rock do
not she's the rock of the music industry
right now I also don't like I joke a lot
about people that definitely do not
listen to this podcast listening to this
podcast I don't put it past the rock to
maybe listen to this he does his
homework
yeah he's aware he doesn't because he
doesn't sleep at all he can't write no
he's Instagram isn't real and people
like pretend about like how busy they
are with all their meetings but he's
legit doing sure he brings his treadmill
with him to hotel rooms and he literally
sets up a giant gym wherever he goes
yeah you're in paradise okay maybe it's
just jealousy now okay what he's doing
is truly impressive I mean really and he
is someone like I mean I'm like I don't
want to come through like when people
are like mocking like why are you trying
to do this I'm like no one's ever done
it I'm like well I'm sorry but the
biggest movie star in the world
used to be a wrestler and that's okay
cuz wrestling is my favorite form but
it's still like a real it's not yeah
back in the day it's there's a
transition that needs to happen and he
definitely did it needs kicking ass yep
so maybe we're all speaking laughs you
laughs at his own jokes yeah so he's
terrible okay the other question every
single guess is tell us your worst pants
shooting story or close call but you can
only use three words or three small
phrases or some combination some mine
for example is college jogging front
lawn I mean I ran track in college okay
all right cool story there's a serial
that I have we use three words or three
small phrases no long winded trattman
all-bran running woods all right hey
that's very similar to lots of fiber in
that theory also spawn not spawn no just
like oh yeah like you feel it too balls
I don't know why I decided to run 12
miles today at Mile six the furthest
possible place for my house is when the
body starts to digest it very fun okay
someone to know on average how drunk
were you during the filming of your
bachelor season not that I'm not a big
drinker I
and people make way big of a deal about
the alcohol on the show it's available
yeah you are often bored and some people
when they're bored drink a lot yeah some
people don't I don't that's a very
politically correct answer I mean it's
also just like make you drink as if like
you have to be in the bachelor before we
start everyone take your five shots you
know like that doesn't happen yeah
that's good to know someone to know
what's his greatest work as of now like
what am I most proud of kind of thing I
guess however you want to interpret that
I mean I feel like you're really second
pump in this natural habit which I just
got privy to the full packaging was
really proud of that and I really smells
amazing I just got the smell a bunch of
thank you and they're great I'm very
proud of that but more fun answer would
be I do have and I was recently shown a
clip of it an episode of Family Guy
coming up it's a quick beat it's a quick
cut too so that has been the highlight
of of all the things that have come from
being on the show that is yeah that's
pretty cool I am yeah that's something
that be super [ __ ] proud of that's
very cool
some snow has he gotten dumped again
recently hell yeah I listen to his
podcast wide open thank you
I opened up my own my podcast by kind of
playing I mean I did I mean a sense I
was hanging out this girl and and and
she decided that we were hanging out too
much and I have since I heard were
plenty of times but I did I dug her and
I was curious about her in the sense
that I don't get curious very often very
easily at this point in my life
mm-hmm I mean yeah I don't know what
like maybe it's cynical maybe it's just
getting older and have it like when
you're younger you meet someone you're
like let's maybe what should we get
married I like you you know standards
and practices no I sure you can say that
but I think it's just more realistic
it's a combination of like like when
you're younger you're naive and lack
perspective but like the world is a
little bit more exciting and you take
risk when you're older you get in
perspective and and that's helpful in
life to you but as a result it can be
perceived as cynicism because you're
just like no you're practical so it's
just a little less exciting anyways yeah
excited about someone that was like an
yeah
but I've heard from her plenty of times
since then all right
that's just my ego saying she actually
likes me the plenty of times is her
going please stop calling me sometimes
please stop contact keeps writing back
no she like you should know it's one of
those like poke ends like don't forget
about me I'm still here oh so you're one
of those like you're a break glass in
case of emergency person maybe I didn't
like have I mean my my real thought is
like we actually dug each other and she
doesn't want to have a boyfriend and it
was yeah that's better I was like very
like you are the hurt like you're like
you're the man of her dreams but she
can't so she's I don't know just simmer
on the stove either way
yeah we we stopped hanging out so
journey continues someone know what's
the best advice you've ever been given
[Music]
don't sweat the small stuff okay that
seems cliché but that's real it's good I
mean I like it if you're the smartest
person in the room you're in the wrong
room I like that one yeah okay that's
very very true I remember one time I
listened to a talk that Snoop Dogg gave
and Snoop Dogg said I surround myself
with people so I'm the dumbest person in
my whole team and I was like that was
the most intelligent thing I've ever
heard he's like I don't want to be
smarter than anyone on my team no I also
like in that's it that's great advice
also like I asked I also point out like
there's been a red flag for me of dating
as and I've done this and recently and
you meet someone and if I noticed that
amongst her friends she's clearly like
the queen she's clearly the prettiest
one and all her friends Revere her to me
that's a red flag oh yeah
because she's like she's clearly chosen
her friends to like validate her and
it's just I've no ties and it's it's
very difficult to live up and that's
person's expectations as a partner if
you're not a pushover yeah when you get
chosen how can you be part of it
so but that's kind of the same vein of
someone who has a confidence to be in
room a room where they're learning from
other people and they know they're maybe
not the smartest or the yeah they're not
the king
yeah or the Queen the confidence to feel
inadequate or just like to once they are
on our equals or people who are who you
admire or you look up to role models
Mentors
yeah it's a it's a lack of ego someone
to know describe your first kiss in
three words awesome it was great it was
great I was very excited she was short
I'm tall she was standing I was on the
street curb so she was kind of that cute
like she was mister we made out and then
I was like in the eighth grade I
sprinted home I was at my friend's house
I've never ran I was the tracks that kid
I just like pure excitement that was
like just like my hands I was I mean I
vividly remember I I remember I was very
thrilled first time I had sex was
different I was terrified happened sure
she's pregnant and I probably have a
disease you got like Wow okay well I
think that's the perfect way to end this
podcast Nick thank you thanks for making
time but before you leave we give
everyone a gift for being here and it's
a personal note so I haven't just new
podcasting you do like you you have this
a lot a nice structure I mean we've been
doing it for five or six years really
great I'm just kind of like hey do you
want to talk about some [ __ ] all right
thanks for coming by do you want me to
say in bed or something oh no
did you write these mmm perhaps because
I've never I haven't read this yet but
it's long yeah yeah that's what they all
say
that's what she said some of your past
teachers have brought your essential
oils that support yeah and some of those
people likely use it as
well that's literally their business so
stay out of it yeah interesting
essential oils it's funny being the guy
from The Bachelor who had some sex on it
and was like jokingly known as the
sexual bachelor so when I come out with
essential oil company the immediate
thought is like some sort of like sex
oils essential oils are not that like I
wouldn't would not recommend
masturbating right in your skin real
fast okay Nick where can people actually
find these essential oils to use them
for the essential purposes you didn't
have to eat that cooking oils calm and
NHL so natural habits on Instagram cool
[Music]
yeah okay an NH oils calm and then
website cool where can people find you
Nick Viall
on Instagram that's fine by all Nicolas
I'm I'm in very insecure about my
Twitter I know you said you like Twitter
it took me so long to find your Twitter
to be able to post to ask for questions
yes I all nicholas 28 which was my
monster threat when i was in college i
came up with some was like hey get a
twitter is like I'll just use this I
don't need people to find me and then I
got like verified overnight and you
can't you can't change it even if you're
verified where can people find your new
podcast the vial files I mean not
Instagram bio files are my Instagram or
vial files on iTunes alright YouTube you
can watch on YouTube it's available if
you wanna watch us maybe you'll come on
one day yeah I would love to look out in
the future I will be on the vile files
co-hosting talking about all the things
just fully fully shaming them feel like
I might need some more structure I'm
happy to provide sort of that thank you
for being checkout natural habits I mean
it really smells amazing so and it's
USDA Organic anxiety headaches all of it
mental clarity body detox I mean that's
what we all are trying to trying to
right mm-hmm
I'll see you guys next time another
episode of not too deep goodbye too deep
toady Totti this episode of not too deep
is brought to you by Merc re it is a
selling app that makes it fast and easy
to sell almost anything you just take a
few pics add a description and boom your
item is listed with buyers in all 50
states stuff really cells and everything
ships easily so there's never any
awkward meetups you can find Macari on
the App Store
that's Macari Emmy RCA our I or go to
Macari comm peeve of a completely
science back to work out method based on
mastering precise movements to create
beautiful muscle tone in less time using
less energy they are sponsoring this
episode of not too deep and get into
this download the app watch tutorials
and see dozens of before and after
pictures then tripe evolve free for one
month and get 50% off the premium peeve
of equipment kit at people.com slash
grace this is the best deal they have
anywhere get a free trial for one month
and 50% off the premium kebab equipment
kit at P valve comm such grace that's P
valve comm / grace
[Music]